he is keenan thompson the star of kenan
that debuted
on nbc earlier this month and you can
catch it
uh on nbc tuesdays at 8 30 p.m eastern
and then right on uh
right on peacock the next day good to
see you keenan and nice point well you
know what it's right there
i've got a little bit of peacock
branding in my home office uh there may
be an eye on rich and eisen but i'm a
team player
you know what i'm saying i'm jealous i'm
i don't have anything i'm just oh i can
i can send one for you if that's new if
would you like yeah
i would i would like very much thank you
you know because if if you were
on the show in person if there was no
pandemic you know there would be some
sort of giveaway you know so
uh yeah i mean we'd be doing all kind of
events high-fiving and kissing the
babies but
absolutely so um i guess let's get into
it you you're
are you you're from atlanta correct are
you from atlanta georgia
i am i was raised there i was born in
columbus ohio but
my parents moved when i was like nine
months old so okay i'm very much from
atlanta
okay so is that a is that your sports
fandom if
at all is that where you no you know
atlanta people we are
loyal across the board so i'm braves
hawks falcons the whole nine i was
thrashers too for a little while but
then that went away
and then what's our soccer team i think
it might be the
f flame you've got me totally stumped
are you
saying that you'd be into soccer for
atlanta or you are
maybe we have we you know atlanta just
supports atlanta
basically so that's how we get down so
who was your who was your
guy athlete growing up that you you
looked up to
or you definitely were gonna follow no
matter what you know it wasn't even a
falcons guy it was actually
um my man uh tony dorsett which is why
i'm i'm big on the number 33
you know like really big on the number
33
and i used to just love tony dorsett
because that 33 would just be running up
and down the field
you know and that was in his cowboys day
so that was
kind of the only thing i was rooting for
over there but as far as my falcons were
concerned the dion days were excellent
the big days were crazy
um and you know our julio days are are
pretty dynamic so
you know it's all good so dion is
uh you know that's the georgia dome he
built they would he would tell you it
was his house that he built
absolutely he i mean prime time baby
have you ever come across dion have you
ever met him
i i yelled at him and i
i shouldn't have it we were
we were leaving lax and he was walking
with his driver and
you know i know that route to to walk
with your driver
to the garage or whatever but i was
going i think
to my rental car or something because i
left and come back really quickly
so they were about to get on an elevator
or something and we're like outside the
airport across the street
you know and he's thinking probably he's
safe you know what i mean
coming away from the crowds and stuff
like that and here comes this
you know this guy yelling yo prime time
and he just you know waved with his back
turned and i was that was my dion
experience
yeah i i have actually been fortunate
enough to walk through
airports with dion sanders
yeah i mean you have to he's got that
quick first step and i i
have done that and he is
easily the most famous person i've ever
walked through an airport with
i can believe it hands down right his
welcoming i think was it
is it mississippi where it's coaching
now that's where he is he's in jail
that was crazy that was amazing he just
loves to coach i mean that's
if that's where he had to go that's
where he had to go and he's going to be
he's going to be
dynamite there there's no doubt about
that but he i don't
i i think his must be the money days uh
was definitely before your tenure in
uh snl um because that's when he hosted
saturday night live that's when dion
yeah that's when he couldn't he was at
his hottest
matter yeah
that's when he was really up there who's
the best um
athlete um you have been around
for the comedy chops who's the best one
that you have
jj was a lot of fun we had jj watt last
year he was
a really cool dude he was super into it
um
i think he had a lot of fun with it
barclay's always a lot of fun that dude
he's just
he's just a character himself you know
he never wants to work more than a
couple of hours
i love it he's great um i mean shaq's
always great you know i mean i guess the
obvious ones that we all
already know are great if they've come
through there they've been awesome tom
brady was
super cool you know but that dude just
you know i don't know he's like a
walking statue like
he's a legend walking amongst us you
know what i mean
it it's amazing so now it's gotten even
better bigger i mean his legend is even
bigger now which is
pretty that dude is crazy here's the god
number number seven that's crazy
it is unbelievable and you know he's
just one of the many people i guess
he's got a lot of towns where his name's
a four-letter word and atlanta is one of
them
for sure oh absolutely and it was a big
burn but
you know i got a place in tampa so i was
able to you know
get a little get back and he's in our
division now i guess that's a
little something you know well you got
to take what you can get
right but tb12 when he was on he
he did uh snl i know jeter did right um
uh yeah i think jeter was before my time
um it was before your time
okay yeah lebron was awesome we had
lebron that's right lebron hosted
he was super cool so lebron lebron in
train wreck
was like legit [ __ ] oh absolutely
he was legit he wasn't just like you
know athlete let me learn three lines
like he has no he gets into it every
other everything he'd like laser focus
is in on
he wants to make it like a very rich
layered experience for people which is
incredible you know he's so giving it's
it's crazy
he didn't have to do that he could
easily just been i'm lebron james and
i'm here and you're welcome but
no he he wants to be entertaining like
that that's so cool
keenan thompson here on the rich eisen
show and we'll talk about your new show
keenan in a second
um that you could see on nbc's tuesdays
at 8 30 p.m eastern
on peacock the next day so um now you
have played barkley correct you have
several times so how how did he like
your
how does he like your version of him he
loves it he's
he's highly amused by it you know um i
didn't have to win him over as hard as i
did steve harvey
like i had to i had to massage steve a
little bit
what happened there what happened there
you know steve
he's a street guy you know street guy
from cleveland you know and and through
chicago he takes himself very seriously
so
he's not one to readily just accept
being
mimicked you know into mockery into
you know making fun of so you know i had
to you know over the years
like show him like no no no i'm not just
a little kid you know nipping at your
heels type stuff this is a
adult massaged mature you know
version of humor because you're such a
personality you're
a giant public figure right i mean i i
remember
again i think it was before your
saturday night live times when
stuart scott got sent up uh on
sportscenter unless maybe you were there
yeah
that was finesse and he did a great job
with it right right finesse did it with
sweet sassy molasses i think is what ray
romano was using as his catchphrase
and but stewart was particularly
you know honored like that's you've kind
of hit it if
snl is yeah you've made you've made
something of yourself you've echoed
across the waters of the world to get
you know
reflected in the pool of snl that's a
cool thing man
right and uh have you run into james
brown since uh
your um take on him with i know but i
heard he said something he said my
hairline was better
than him that that i think he took it
he took it with some love there so
that's good well i mean
i mean there but for the grace of god go
any sports person that there's a
blackout in the middle of the hugest
event that's going on on planet earth
and then you've got to
kill some time but that i mean so how
does that come about when
you you watch it and then you're saying
we're gonna we're gonna do something on
that we have to do
something on this when you're watching
that half that
as they're filling in tap dancing with
two broke girls
uh promos and stuff like that how does
that come about
i mean we didn't really watch that
fiasco happen i think
it was just more familiar with the guys
that are usually hosting
football desks basically when it's big
game time
right i think we knew who was going to
be on the desk for the super bowl the
following day so we just went from there
and those guys are
all pretty familiar like i've done james
brown before in the past
but god bless those guys for you know
handling and being
on their toes is that what happened they
had a blackout that was the blackout at
the super bowl in the in
in in new orleans oh i mean the colin
kaepernick one
the yeah kaepernick yeah yeah and then
the 49ers they had that that blackout oh
that's right
and we did that bit right yeah it was
two broke girls
let me that's right that's right now i
know you're talking gas
got you thank you yeah that's confused i
was like did they have a blackout at the
super bowl the next day
yeah in new orleans on cbs and they're
like you know they're probably
trust me i've been through this before
they're probably sitting in the green
room having lunch having dinner like
they're on for another three hours you
know yeah
you got this made in the shape got to
get back out there
two broke girls
yeah that was a good show very funny
show oh
man what else that was fantastic and
then uh
then uh your your other um
uh skit that jumps out to me was david
ortiz
for all those have you run into him has
have you been able to
connect with him since doing a big poppy
i love that dude i have not
physically run into him but yeah i
remember he posted
like a tweet or a picture of him when we
first did it or something
we made a joke about equinox and the
kind of equinox he
you know is uh promoting basically and
it was iguana knox
you know it's the it's a lot of iguanas
around while you're working out and he
took a picture of him pointing to an
iguana it was like i found our first uh
member so he you know he took it with
love too so
that dude is great he is i mean it's
some all-time great stuff
keenan thompson here on the rich eisen
show okay so let's get to your your
current show
uh on nbc and um
you know you you've been at this for
quite some time keenan and now to have a
show with your
name on it that's gotta be something
with uh
with you know chris redd who obviously
you know and don
johnson for crying out loud who's you
know og to say the least i mean
right exactly this has got to be pretty
neat for you
oh it's incredible man and it's a it's a
lot it's it's very
you know i can't really say sure it's
it's
i'm trying to stay away from the word
overwhelming as well you know but
it's a lot seeing your name plastered on
billboards or
you know shuttle vans around here and
signs and chairs and
you know it's a big push so i feel
the level of responsibility that i think
i should be feeling
and i think i'm surrounded by a
wonderful cast to help me push this
thing uphill so
i feel good about it and you know the
responses have all been like really
positive so
we just want people to show up and
improve and you know
make the numbers make sense for these
people to like let us keep it all
can you play a widow dad a two two girls
an
atlanta morning show guy and your name
is
keenan in the show is is is there any
sort of actual biographical material
that's in this
at all or what it is i mean the only
difference is i'm not a widower you know
like i i do have the you know
i understand the circus of jungling
working a couple of kids and
stuff like that but thank god i have my
wife so i can only imagine
how you know someone else uh
that would be in my character situation
would deal with that basically and
that's kind of the adventure i'm on and
i'm
discovering some really interesting
moments i think
and you know still finding ways to be
really funny at the same time so
it's been yeah it i i i think it's
you know obviously an important subject
matter and and then you're getting to
to have the cast that you have here have
you
at any point in time have you been able
to broach miami vice with don johnson
have you
oh yeah constantly that's all
like our first couple days together
that's all i wanted to hear and he
wanted to talk about it you know
he's talking about amy knights and like
how it used to be because you know
at the same time he's an actor's actor
so you know he
worked up to get to that and you know
you should be able to
you know enjoy the fruits of the labor a
little bit
so he's telling me all of those good
like
stories that i can only imagine what it
must have been like so
yeah that dude is the best are they safe
for work
or they are so not safe for work at all
but tweens does dudes
pretty good stuff it's what we're so it
would be what
i would personally hope for is what
you're saying these types of stories
from times times 10.
yeah it's pretty great i mean it's
incredible like you can just
you almost can feel the setting
basically like if you've ever been to
florida
or you know spent any time winter or
summer you can
you can imagine yeah i just spent a
masculine super bowl there so
uh yeah there you go you stay in the
house for a while
uh make sure you always keep your smell
and taste going
let's get it all working uh it was an
interesting time in in tampa florida for
sure
hey uh keenan thanks for the time really
appreciate it congrats on
uh your show thank you man like i said
i've been a big fan of yours since
your first second on saturday night live
and you were a featured player in 2003.
was that
29 of snl is that what that was that's
right
i mean that is unbelievable
congratulations on everything going on
for you and i'd love to do this again
when you whenever you'd like
thank you very much likewise we'll make
it happen for sure i just realized that
that's a paddle back there
it is actually yeah uh here it is it's a
paddle that's interesting
you know when uh when my show first
started is uh i got a friend of mine who
uh
uh works with cedar you know to light up
cigars
like cedar sticks and he made this for
me and
that's a good dude so it you know as a
father of three though it
comes in a little handy sometimes as
well you know sometimes you
gotta show them what could happen that's
true it's
it's it's it's a a memento and a threat
at the same time
that's my that's why i'm father of the
year every year yeah yeah good luck with
explaining that thanks again uh can
watch keenan on nbc's tuesdays at 8 30
p.m on nbc and then on peacock the very
next day
at keenan thompson on both twitter and
instagram right here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here